welcome to this video playing playing
playing playing lake lake of rocks and
at some calc on yeah okay what should I
play a good i could play this this line
again Smith Slav cap off variation she's
going for the snide g5 line I guess now
95 e6 Queenie to but this is where my
theoretical knowledge ends okay I think
you need to play Knight b6 now aged 65
something like that is I think the right
right way to play yeah this seems to be
okay for now but how is it how it is Cal
how is it continued hmm maybe i can add
I don't like the night on b6 maybe I can
play night turn to d5 to Queen 85
something like that we went to e5 check
mm yeah the store seems to be a
theoretical line but I'm not following
it knowingly just develops night c4
probably at some point
young loke Aslan this looks looks rather
rather aggressive and we had like that
like to have should be five hmm
okay some nights you for yeah I wonder
if I castle if I castle short and he's
probably going to play very quickly I
g-form came maybe I can first play rook
c8 yes but I didn't think this is some
dangerous because Queenie 6 noise and
then in a pin I can play 96 check can
play 96 Bishop d6 center Queen takes a
six hmm
yeah this is bad
I'm thinking about the possible possible
Queen sexy but it's not not really on
yeah talk about talk about a dead end
game wow he's got two bishops and the
bishop on d6 in particular is really a
pest cannot Castle short so on yeah
very ugly position but I have so ever
may be 94 something mighty form
attacking d6 yeah this is in fact
playable attacking f2 also if if he
needs to now play Bishop g3 and I can
take it then I'm okay Bishop d5 I can
take d 6 I think okay this isn't so bad
very lucky I thought the first first
thought that I'm basically toast with
this still seems to be okay maybe he's
got some spectacular move Knight f5 or
something 95mm and i can i can probably
take f 295 ef5 rock d 5 is the idea like
to waiting no I'm not sure aha so he
allows me to take here they are possible
that they are Bishop d5 has the problem
yeah what whatever I I need to take it
no not much choice ok d1 or h1 prolly t1
he's got Bishop d7 as well this could be
the point came but at the end i can i
can play 93 here takes g7 i'll get back
back on g2 maybe this is still playable
I'll always get back to tune the text g7
I think I is taking age 6 mm is taking
age 6 attacking the night and I don't
want to take on g2 with an ID but what
what else is them probably am probably
have to now always I always have this
hope for I can always hope for opposite
colored bishops yeah and this Bishop is
actually nicely protecting the Sun this
night hmm I've got a look h 8 2 h 2 mm
hmm maybe this isn't so bad yeah a sort
of stumbled into this position and not
it's not like I planned any of that but
it seems to be okay for black the H pawn
is weak at the moment and I have to pass
us enf porn the main main assured the
moment is the time I'm down in time make
it take a seven I don't mind you
threaten 96 check so I went I went to
shop f3 to get out of them this threat
okay let's let's grab the spawn
it's no one yeah probably let's let's
roll enf porn check
don't have much time so just just push
this and hope for the best
yeah III in King at five I'm very active
yeah III alone is pretty good now is e
to f3 threatened yeah I guess this
should win unless I'm I'm blundering
something yeah it's two points not just
one
now this probably wasn't the most
precise way to time work check
technically check check yeah I don't
want to check get his pawns a bit
forward
King Jack cannot help to defer check
check check mate yeah the King the king
place light like he did in the game that
King hell doesn't help to defend and the
and-one spawns can get under attack by
my by my rook wow that's pretty pretty
amazed that I got out of this it looked
this is the stage it looked a look
terrible probably this channel well the
computer doesn't mind this position so
much it gives wyd an edge but nothing
nothing in particular so a five-term
yeah probably i should go night you for
here he has probably some better way to
to spend the tempo yeah look h3 one is
much stronger intending night f5 well
yeah I'm a typical reflex with a 394 was
better alone no after this you can even
go go here however this is some yeah the
computer says why this winning i'm not
sure about that it could be it could be
of course but yeah so cannot castle it's
probably winning him okay and now after
94 I'm pretty much back in business and
after that I'm better I hear night f2
was stronger you now I probably night f2
look everyone and then IG for him yeah
difficult already not much time but this
sir was at least a playable continuation
and it's just much easier to play with
black with the pawns he cannot easily
push the pawns because of this lonely
but important day for porn all right I
hope you enjoyed the game thanks for
watching